hi there
my name is Katherine Kuan I'm a
developer advocate on the Google
developer relations team this video
explains in a little more detail about
the Valentine's Day app that was first
introduced in the previous video of the
playlist be sure to watch that one first
if you haven't already so to pick up
where we left off we you are customizing
this app containing a list of coupons
for your Valentine we'll take a look now
under the hood and see how the views for
one coupon is constructed for each
coupon we start with a relative layout
then we place an image view inside of it
which stretches the whole width and
height of the relative layout we proceed
by adding a view at the bottom with a
slight gradient so the text doesn't
blend in with the photo on top of the
gradient overlay we then add the title
of the coupon the last view is a text
view containing the description and
there you have the completed view we
took the individual coupon views and
then laid them out into a grid view the
number of columns in the grid adapts
based on screen width for optimal
viewing of the app on all device sizes
on phones like the nexus 5 it will be a
single column grid which is essentially
a list and it's the same in both
portrait and landscape mode on topics
like Nexus 7 it will be two columns in
portrait but three columns in landscape
on tablets like Nexus 10 we have a three
column grid in landscape and portrait
mode for information how the resource
folders are named and setup see the
provided link keep in mind that when
you're displaying all these images on
such high resolution screens you may
consider sizing down your images so that
when they're all loaded up and the users
scrolling through the list they don't
run out of memory if you still have
performance issues then you can read
more about bitmaps with this link now
let's talk about how the sharing part of
the app works when the user taps on a
coupon we build up a share intent using
the share compact class and the user can
pick which app to share to the intent is
composed of text
the title and description of the coupon
a Content URI that maps to the image and
a type for the image you'll notice that
we don't pass the image file directly
but rather our content URI that the
framework uses to find the image in this
case the hangouts app we'll try to
figure out what the URI points to and it
will reach our asset provider class
which then translates this your I into a
file descriptor within write permissions
to access the image and that's how the
giraffe image ends up in the hangouts
app within the conversation thread the
asset provider is an example of a
content provider content providers can
be used to access the database or files
like in our case this link shows you
where you can get more info on content
providers so that's the overview of
everything hope that helps and good luck
with building your app